[Music]
i've always admired that hat
hello chess
since you wouldn't be needing it anymore
would you consider bequeathing it to me
how dare you
it is a formal execution i would like to
look my best you know
there's a pity about all this
i was looking forward to seeing you fat
awaken
i was rather good at it well they're not
i really do love that hat
i would wear it to all the finest
occasions
hey there it's mark and welcome to a
positively exciting new episode of rt
essentials this one is bound to leave
you feline fine especially if you're one
of the many allurophiles out there it
means lover of cats did my hysterical
puns already give that away
oh boy let's not be shy about how much
we love our furry little friends after
all research has shown that cat owners
have better psychological health are
less prone to stress and form stronger
human relationships than those without
pets so let's dispel all those qualified
things i say about crazy cat people
i will try my best to have no more puns
for the rest of this episode but they're
just so perfect today we celebrate the
most iconic and recognizable felines to
ever graze the silver screen now there's
no lines no tigers no jaguars we're
talking traditional house cats the live
action and the animated version so
without further ado let's dig in these
are the most legendary kitties in cinema
puss puss in boots
[Music]
pouncing in first is puss the titular
character in the 2011 dreamworks
animation film puss in boots he's
adorable he's swashbuckling smooth
talking cavalier hat wearing he's an
orange tabby with big green eyes and a
spanish accent he also carries a little
cute sword and sometimes sports a cape
kind of like zoro it's actually a lot
like zoro and that's because he's a
direct parody of the legendary mass
vigilante and he's even voiced by
antonio banderas who famously portrayed
zorro in two live action films though
many of us fell in love with puss in
boots when he first became an ally to
shrek and donkey in 2004 shrek 2 the
character has been prominent in european
fairy tales since the 1500s initially
appearing in the writings of italian
author giovanni francesco straparola
basically puss his lineages he's
italian-born british shorthair with a
spanish accent and i would love to see
those 23andme results you've got to
hurry up
he's a cute little father why are you
not using your gloves would you please
just shut up i'm on it just use your
club be quiet you're close i don't have
any claws all right
was that him hulk
for the films puss was based on the real
cats owned by director andrew adamson
and effect supervisor ken bielenberg and
once banderas was on board the animators
studied the actors live-action zorro
flick for insight into how push should
be depicted banderas chose to use a deep
breathy voice for puss as opposed to the
high-pitched approach that was
originally intended this was because
they wanted to give the effect of a lion
trapped in the little body of a cat his
choice helped the filmmakers reimagine
the character in a new way a tiny
creature who pays no mind to his
physical size and limitations and
instead leads to granois existence the
cape cat crusader was such a scene
stealer in shrek 2 that the heads of
dreamworks almost immediately decided to
develop the film that focused on puss's
origins which spawned the first solo
puss and boots feature directed by chris
miller and written by tom wheeler the
film was a commercial and critical
success and spawned a television
spin-off series and a sequel yes set for
release in december 2022 long live puss
in boots
mr tinkles cats and dog you are all five
go home now
do not ask why
you have no one to blame but yourself
unless of course you have a dog then you
can blame him
in fact you know what take him when he
get home that is all the comedy
adventure cats and dogs uncovers the
true nature of the relationship between
canine and kitty two great armies waging
secret wars that humans aren't even
aware of this film adds plenty of fuel
to the cat person versus dog person
debate but let's face it we already know
where we stand and we're here for mr
tinkles mr tinkles is a fluffy white
persian cat with bright yellow eyes you
just want to squeeze his face he's so
cute but do not be fooled mr tinkles is
also a cruel evil genius who won't be
satisfied until every last person on
earth is allergic to dogs he employs a
large network of hench cats willing to
execute his dirty deeds including his
dim-witted sidekick calico and exotic
shorthair i always knew cats were
secretly plotting to take over the world
while dogs were busy doing things like
playing fetch and showing us affection
refuse well they
will be put to slate
hold the camera still idiots you have
until midnight to comply
[Laughter]
we're gonna save them right right this
is way over our heads
to pull off this live-action fur fest of
a film 33 cats and 27 dogs were used
along with dozens of animatronic puppets
and cgi because it's pretty hard to
train a real cat to speak on commands
trust me i have tried
to get mr tinkles right it took two
real-life persian cats named fritz and
foster a life-size puppet with six
puppeteers hiding under floorboard and a
team of visual effects artists top that
off with the expert voice acting of sean
hayes and you've got yourself one
ferocious antagonist
the cheshire cat alice in wonderland
most everyone's mad here
[Laughter]
you
may have noticed
that i'm not all there
myself
disney's 13th animated feature alice in
wonderland was based on the legendary
alice book by louis carroll and first
premiered in july of 1951. it featured
the vocal talents of catherine beaumont
as alice edwin as mad hatter and of
course sterling holloway as the cheshire
cat
when you think of the cheshire cat
disney's original version is probably
what comes to mind his pink and purple
stripes that permanent grin his
mischievous ways and though he was first
popularized by carol's novel alice's
adventures in wonderland published back
in 1865 the idea of a grinning cheshire
cat actually dates back to 18th century
literature
carol's memoir suggests that he was
inspired after seeing a carving of a
cheshire cat with a giant smile etched
into the wall at brimstage all in world
but other theories suggest that carol
took his inspiration from a gargoyle in
cranley though no one knows for certain
why the anthropomorphic cat suddenly
entered the literary zeitgeist centuries
ago one thing we do know for sure is
that his popularity only seems to grow
along with that smile
what do you call yourself
alice see alex
there's been some debate about that i
never get involved in politics
it must be on your way
what way all i want to do is wake up
from the stream
fine
i'll take you to the hair and the hatter
but that's the end of it
[Applause]
in 2010 tim burton and walt disney
pictures released their reimagined
live-action version of carol's works the
film was praised for its visual style
and special effects and ended up
grossing get this over a billion dollars
of the worldwide box office becoming the
fifth highest grossing film of all time
which is numerical evidence of society's
overwhelming love for cats all right
that might be a stretch but i do believe
that cheshire cat played a large role in
that film's success
burton's cheshire cat was a cgi rendered
grey tabby with light blue stripes
voiced by celebrated english actor
stephen fry not too shabby tabby
sassy homeward bound the incredible
journey i was just curious
oh
like my mother always said curiosity
killed the dog sassy can you pull those
things out i'll try
zach you've got my lift you gotta
lift it's all right i'm a professional
they look like they're in deep
really deep
you can't make a cat list and not expect
things to get sassy literally like the
next cat on our list who is named sassy
and she's one of the main protagonists
from the film that really terrified me
from porcupines homeward bound the
incredible journey sassy and her canine
companions shadow and chance embark on a
treacherous journey through the
california wilderness to find their way
back home after convincing themselves
that their owners the siever family have
left them for good but you can't blame
the sievers for dropping off their
beloved fur balls at a neighbor's ranch
this was before pet friendly travel
accommodations like sir barks a lot were
trendy and instagram cats were more
famous than their owners sassy is a
medium-sized himalayan who lives up to
her name often reminding chance that
cats rule and dogs drool
okay dog people relax those are sassy's
words not mines i have a dog i love her
and she does drool just saying sassy's
voice might sound familiar and that's
because she was portrayed by an oscar
winner sally field and if you're
thinking some of that sass in the film
isn't exactly like the others you'd be
correct because it took 10 different
cats to complete all of the sassiness
he shake that tail baby i don't believe
it
cat calls
nice whiskers baby
so big fella what are you in for sassy
sassy
i told you to run away i never listened
to dogs
so to put things into perspective sassy
had 10 times the amount of stunt doubles
that captain america required an end
game
speaking of which i'm still waiting for
marvel to respond to my position to make
sassy one of the avengers did they even
see the scene where sassy gets swept
into a fast-moving river falls down a
giant waterfall and lives to tell the
tale not all superheroes wear capes some
of them have collars ps no cats were
harmed in the making of that scene most
of that sequence was a fake cat with a
real cat close-up shot safely and
separately
goose captain marvel get that thing away
how'd that get in here huh
the cat
this isn't what you're afraid of is it
that's not a cat
that's a fluke a flurking
so marvel may not adopt sassy but they
did give us goose the breakout superhero
from the 2019 film captain marvel on the
surface goose resembles your typical
orange tabby house cat but trust me when
i say this you do not want to get on her
bad side that's because goose is
actually a flurkin and forkins are
dangerous aliens with hidden tentacles
that can shoot out of their mouth and
swallow up large objects they can also
weigh hundreds of eggs at a time and
produce an insane amount of offspring in
the films goose shares a strong bond
with carol danvers aka captain marvel
played by brie larson but in real life
goose is played by reggie a 12 year old
feline actor who is cast because of how
expressive his face is and he's also
just you know so adorable there were
three stunt cats gonzo rizzo and archie
who would fill in for reggie a certain
time and for the insane shots like that
whole goose shooting tentacles out of
his mouth thing i mentioned before it
was a cgi cat that was implemented goose
and danvers are an impressive on-screen
duo but off-screen larson has a severe
cat allergy so many of the scenes
require the use of a stuffed cat
that was a close call huh goosey huh
those bad guys still in there somewhere
oh [ __ ] and serious efforts were
made to reduce larsen screen time with
reggie and the other kitties in an
interview arson exclaimed it's weird how
you can train and get your body to do
insane things but allergies are kind of
hard to stop allergies aside goose
became an internet sensation immediately
with the trending goose the cat hashtags
on social media and tons of fan art
circulating the internet okay hear me
out assassin goose solo marvel road trip
movie come on who's not paying to see
them
jinx meet the parents oh
oh
oh
oh
my god
oh didn't see no
oh
next up is jinx more formally known as
mr jinx the himalayan hero from the j
roach comedy meet the parents jinx is
the pride and joy of jack burns a
retired cia agent and a vietnam war
veteran who strongly dislikes his
daughter's boyfriend greg so when greg
accidentally lets jinx outside you can
imagine how problematic that is
especially since jack is played by
robert de niro who you really do not
want to mess with look at good fellas or
casino or pretty much any other de niro
movie anyways you get the point he's
intimidating and he loves his cat the
jinx jack craig dynamic is one of the
most hilarious elements of meet the
parents and thanks to the film's
popularity jinx became one of the most
memorable cats ever to hit the big time
oh god
whoa jinx
jinx don't do it
don't do it no no
jinx was played by two different
himalayan cats bailey and misha in case
one of them wasn't cooperating which
happened pretty often because himalayan
cats are a notoriously difficult breed
to train while filming de niro grew to
love bailey and misha and he'd carry
treats in his pockets to feed them in
between scenes he also wanted to train
the cats himself but that would have
been too time consuming i'm not gonna
lie though i'd pay a lot of money to see
behind the scenes footage of de niro
training a difficult himalayan cat you
meowin at me you yelling at me i'm the
only one here the trainers hired for the
film suggested that roach opt for a more
agreeable breed but he declined and
we're glad he did because it's hard to
imagine mr jinx being any other way also
can we take a moment to appreciate the
jinxy cat knows how to use a toilet like
a human how do i get my dog molly to
pull that off
snowbell stuart little humiliation
i'm gonna kill you here
come back here
[Music]
they shape cat toys into mice for a
reason folks enter snowbell a fluffy
white persian and one of the main
antagonists in the stuart little
franchise snowbell does not like that
steward a kindhearted mouse has been
adopted into the little family and is
now considered his master snowbell keeps
this mouse with a pet cat dynamic secret
from his alley cop friends as it's a
source of serious embarrassment when the
alley cats start to find out about
stuart and try to hunt him snowville has
a change of heart and defends his little
mouse master in order to get the cats to
move and look in the right direction the
trainers used laser pointers many of the
scenes were established using real
animals while the more complex sequences
were achieved using special effects also
this is one of those talking animal
movies where their mouths move in sync
with the dialogue so that was cgi and i
hope you knew that snowbell's voice was
brought to us by actor nathan lane who
might have one of the most recognizable
voices in cinema ever remember this one
when the world turns its back on you you
turn your back on the world
yeah that's wayne who voiced timon in
the lion king by the way meerkats are
not members of the cat family despite
their name i know it was demanding to me
as well look let's get one thing
straight i'm doing this for the littles
all right they love you george loves you
they're all miserable without you
but snowmelt
you said i know what i said i
i lied okay
welcome to manhattan i'm the one that
hates you
a snow bell
you do care
[Music]
uh yeah yeah okay okay that's enough
back to snowbell his character was based
on a cat that director rob minkoff had
in his home during childhood and after
shooting was complete minkoff actually
adopted the cat that played snowbell
well one of the five cats that actually
played snowbell and thanks to the
popularity of the stuart little films
and the immense love for snowville the
persian cat breed became even more
popular in europe and america thanks
hocus pocus you're my kitty now
you'll have milk and tuna fish every day
and you'll only hunt mice for fun you're
going to turn me into one of those fat
useless contended house cats
you bet you
cats have long been prevalent in
folklore thought to possess magical
abilities and often portrayed as
companions to supernatural beings
through the 1993 disney film hocus pocus
a tale of three resurrected witches from
salem massachusetts was wise to
prominently feature a cat named binks
well his full name is actually thackery
binks and he was once a 17th century
human boy who after insulting the
witches was turned into an immoral
short-haired black cat with yellow eyes
or really only interested in the things
the cat version no offense to thackery
but
i just like the cat better man you can't
keep blaming yourself for that
that happened so long ago take good care
of danny max you'll never know how
precious she is
until you lose her
eight real-life black cats were used to
play binks their names stimpy felix mad
cat killer rio tomcat clyde and frady
cat and with such an eclectic group of
felines all possessing different
personalities and skills director kenny
ortega was able to call upon specific
cats for specific things moments i'm
assuming fraidy cat came in handy during
the scenes where pinks had to face the
evil witches for certain shots trainers
would hide buzzers in the actress
clothing to get the cat to run towards
set actor then the cats would be
rewarded with a treat additionally the
cats would respond to visual and verbal
cues for the scenes where binks is
talking mouth moving and all a real
cat's body was combined with a computer
animated head and for some of the more
difficult action sequences animatronic
cats were used six in total which means
there's a bunch of bing's puppets out
there somewhere in the world i've seen a
total of zero on ebay i'll keep checking
don't you worry
the aristocats the aristocats
gee i'm gonna miss them too well
we almost had a father yeah
let's go back to bed
[Music]
goodnight duchess
[Music]
these next cool cats are known as the
aristocats and they're the stars of the
animated disney feature the aristocats
yeah they're so cool they got an entire
movie named after them which also will
be the case when my sassy and goose
marvel movie gets made it will happen by
god
the film was released in 1970 and
believe it or not this was the last film
project to be approved by mr walt disney
himself it's also a perfect time to
point out the disney studios are
responsible for five of the ten cat
movies on this list further proving the
power of the cat and mouse dynamics
[Music]
really always come back here haven't you
forgotten something darling
thank you miss fufu for letting me ride
on your back
you're quite welcome young man
how's that mama
very good darling that was very nice the
aristocats features an elegant cat named
duchess her three kittens a feral named
thomas o'malley and scat cat who eat a
gang of jazz playing alley cats art
director and writer ken anderson spent a
year and a half developing the designs
for the film's characters and five of
disney's legendary nine old men worked
on it for those unfamiliar with the nine
old men they were the core animators
behind countless disney classics
including snow white and the seven
dwarfs pinocchio fantasia cinderella
peter pan and of course alice in
wonderland so they're partially
responsible for our perception of the
cheshire cat and speaking of the
cheshire cat sterling holloway also lent
his vocal talents to the character
roguefort in this film though roguefort
is actually a house mouse he gets an
honorable mention for being a friend to
the cats and assisting them in their
expulsion of the evil butler edgar
friends of felines are friends of mine
jonesy
alien come on baby
hey
[Music]
last but certainly not least is jonesy
from the 1979 sci-fi horror film alien
directed by ridley scott and starring
sigourney weaver and my close personal
friend tom skerritt jonesy also referred
to as jones is an orange short-haired
tabby whose task aboard the commercial
starship nostromo was to control rodents
i didn't realize rodents were floating
around space either but i guess i'm not
terribly surprised jonesy also proved to
be a source of entertainment and comfort
for the crew while they were on their
long journeys but once again just
because he's cuddly and is cute doesn't
mean he should be underestimated just
like me oh and spoiler alert when a
xenomorph you know those terrifying
extraterrestrial creatures with the
mouse wreaks havoc on nostromo and kills
most of the crew it's just jonesy and
sigourney weaver's character ripley that
survived
jonesy was even confronted by the alien
at one point but scared the creature off
with i guess his striking good looks
that's my story and i'm sticking to it
[Music]
oh it's nice to see you too
[Applause]
[Music]
four cats with varying personalities
were used to portray jonesy and scott
admitted that in order to get shots of
jonesy hissing he placed a german
shepherd behind a board and when jonesy
would walk over the board would get
lifted revealing the dog which would
cause jones to start hissing intensely
scott explained that the german shepherd
was securely fastened with a leash which
is a relief because i'd feel terrible
for any dog that had to come into
contact with an angry jonesy scared off
an alien of all the cool cats on this
list jonesy might arguably cast the
largest shadow he's been referenced in
games like halo world of warcraft and
fortnite and he's also the star of a
graphic novel entitled jonesy nine lives
on the nostromo and he's been at the
center of countless fan debates and
theories my favorite of which suggests
that jonesy might be a forking like
goose all right jonesy you've earned
yourself a role in my goose and sassy
movie and there you have it our
selections for the most legendary cats
in cinema yes there's so many other
iconic felines in films that we didn't
have time to include today like either
milo or otis i can't remember who was
who we have plenty of new episodes on rt
essentials coming your way so i hope
we'll get there eventually thanks for
tuning in i'm mark ellis and to all my
cat lovers out there live long and
possible
[Applause]
[Music]
you